celebrate 10,000 subscribers I hit it we
did it you guys helped a little bit I
did most of the work
no I'm serious I am blown away that I
have hit 10,000 subscribers I'm blown
away at the speed at which things picked
up considering I've started 2017 with
only a little over 1000 so this has been
nuts I said I would do a Q&A up and
taking your questions the last week
maybe a little more than that
so I'm now gonna answer them I am trying
to answer in some form every question
that was asked so if I if I don't answer
your question exactly as you worded it
there's a pretty good chance that it is
kind of folded into an answer to a
another similar question but I want to
try and get through all these and not
have this video be an hour long so let's
get to it and I do want to thank
everyone who sent questions in most of
them or in the comments section of my
top 10 movies of 2017 video some people
send them to me and Twitter some people
emailed me so thank you all let's go why
are you called council of geeks when
it's pretty much just one guy this is a
question I've been fielding for a while
so long story short you go way back to
the beginning of this channel this did
not start out as me ranting at the
camera this started out as a series of
scripted shorts about a group of geeky
friends and that's where the name came
from I have stuck with it even though
these rants are now the primary kind of
content I put out initially I started
doing these to fill in content between
seasons of the scripted stuff so that it
didn't just you know go silent in
between those but as I exhausted you
know my ideas that I liked for the
scripted things this just became the
primary format so I kept the name
anyways because a I just liked it and B
it's kind of a reminder to me that I do
actually want to have more people on the
channel more often it's a little bit
tricky for me to do that a related
question that I got is what happened to
B to the other guys who used to be on
here and the two main ones being Ryan
and Paul who you would
from the the logo that I have for this
channel both of them fairly recently had
kids so it's a little bit tougher to uh
to her angle them than it used to be but
I do want to try and get you know more
people on and have more you know group
discussions I'm looking into the
possibility of crossovers with some
other channels so that's all stuff I'm
exploring so that's another reason I
keep the name it's sort of a reminder to
myself to something I want to get going
and at this point I forget which
commenters said it but at one point
somebody said we are all the council and
I quite like that the idea that the
council is not me the council is all of
us you know my my subscriber is everyone
who comments who takes part in the
conversation so yeah I'm stealing that
idea can you kindly explain what is on
your shelving and on display behind you
yeah I'll try and keep this quick
because there is a fair bit of stuff
we'll start up here up here we have bun
bun because I am a slinky free lance fan
worship the comic is it not nifty umm
I've had him for a long time I love this
guy I I don't keep up with sluggy
freelance as much as I should and that's
partly on purpose I purposefully get
behind several months or even a year or
two so that there were several story
hours completed and then I can just
binge through them but so there's one
button I then got all the sonic
screwdrivers that's all the way down to
over here I'm not gonna pick them up and
show you each one that'll just take
forever but real quick
I've got third fourth eighth war doctor
nine and tens it's the you know it did I
just have one for that it's the same one
Elevens 12s yet Capaldi don't argue with
me that he's not 12 just go with it
River songs the laser screwdriver and
then a couple of kind of custom ones
that basically came with Kitz you know
fit together different parts to make it
the shape and design you want so that
that's those I've got the Lego figures
get these real quick I've got two of
these
I have Lego poison ivy and also like a
Wonder Woman and then next to that so
this this is to malian this is my dragon
and I I really love this guy
yeah don't you yeah so I I don't get to
bring him out as much as I want I love
bringing this guy to UM to renaissance
festivals little kids get really
fascinated by him and I if you can't
figure out he's a puppet but can
basically be operated one-handed because
he's got it's got this little thing that
actually comes out his tail at the back
and I I can operate this one-handed just
press it down to lift the head and twist
it to turn the head so you get a
surprising amount of motion out of just
out of just using the one hand so you
know I can hide this in my pocket and
the tail covers most of it and so yeah
that's that guy so coming down from that
I'll try and burn through these we've
got Totoro we have a Wonder Woman
figurine she's she's one of the new
things I got her for Christmas actually
we have no face behind them as the ps3
then we've got the the n64 over on the
side but I need to try this at some
point I've got Star Wars space punch my
partner got me this you know what we're
gonna celebrate I'm gonna crack this
open that is not that bad so hey and I
plan to keep the can after that so then
next to that we have my Leia Disney
infinity figure I've actually got a
handful of these I never actually played
Disney infinity but when it was
announced that the servers were gonna
get shut down for that game those
figures became dirt cheap especially
secondhand and like Game Stop so I did I
got a whole bunch of ones that I like I
just picked her to put there because I I
like Leia a lot the reason the figures
there at all is the ps2 is behind
because the ps3 that I have isn't back
isn't a model that's backwards
compatible
um and the red light on the the ps2 was
bugging the heck out of me so that's why
she got put there to block that so it
doesn't show up on the camera then we've
got cards against humanity' we have a
rubber duck
done up like the Riddler this guy was
basically a party favor from a a
burlesque show that I went to a villains
themed one I have my Queen alien figure
then there's the gamecube Batgirl
we have gizmo Harley Quinn now there was
briefly a blue Dalek right here the
reason he's not there anymore is he's
not actually mine he's my daughter's uh
he was there temporarily because she she
has way too many stuffed animals so I
told her you don't pick some stuff that
you're okay being put away for now not
like getting rid of but will cycle
things through just to bring the clutter
down in your room and she you know
picked him just sort of set aside and I
thought well great I'll put him on
display but she decides you want to back
and what am I gonna do so then there's
the Super Nintendo down here we've got
vince clortho it's not Zul it is vince
clortho she don't think there's a
difference in the mold for the action
figure between the two but that's what
it said on the box so that's what I go
with and then we've got another version
of Batgirl we've got a little white
tiger there's some stuff down there that
you can't really see from here we've got
Hedwig who's on top of a lava lamp I
mean there's actually even more stuff
behind me that you can't see I'm not
gonna go through all of it but for
instance there is my plush touch acoma
who I love and I would love on more
display but he's a little too big for
any of the other shelves my daughter
calls him big butt kids so I think
that's all that we'll move on what
animated DC movies have you seen and
what one is your favorite as of this
recording I've seen all of them so I
actually can be kind of definitive on
this my own personal favorite and I do
make the distinction between favorite
and best my favorite is
and beyond return of the Joker largely
due to how much I loved what they did
with the Joker in that and how good Mark
Hamill isn't that I think the best one
is probably Batman mask of the phantasm
but beyond that there are there are a
lot of great ones new frontier is
phenomenal how well they were able to
take this really sprawling work and pare
it down to something short and
manageable that's really impressive
Superman indeed versus the elite is I
think one that a lot of people missed
and I wish more people saw that I feel
like that's an underappreciated gem out
of that line that one's really good too
what do you like more Star Wars the last
Jedi or Peter Capaldi's first series as
the doctor okay whoever asked this one
has obviously been paying attention to
my channel because this is a loaded
question because these are both things
that are coming from franchises that I
love that I have a lot of issues with
each as of this moment I probably like
Peter Capaldi's first series as the
doctor better than I like Star Wars the
last Jedi but that's also cuz the pain
of Star Wars the last Jedi is fresher I
think with the benefit of time they
might be a more even footing or maybe
I'll even be more okay with the last
Jedi but as of this recording I I would
take I would rather rewatch Series 8 and
then I that I would the last Jedi
do you play current video games at all
so you may have noticed when I went
through the shelf talking about the
various video game series the most
recent one up there is the ps3 I don't
have a current generation gaming system
and I don't plan to get one there's a
couple of reasons for that the big one
is just I don't have time for to sink
into games anymore I just don't I mean I
have an embarrassingly large number of
games for the ps3 that I haven't beaten
yet an even larger number actually that
I haven't even started and I do plan to
but I mean I've got a backlog in the
last generation I there's no way I'm
buying the new stuff I do keep tabs on
what goes on in sort of video games and
by doing that I'm actually kind of glad
that circumstance has already pushed me
out of keeping up with current
generation cuz there's a lot of crazy
and
Phoebe s going on in video games right
now and I'm kind of glad that I don't
have to deal with it directly what is
your favorite movie favorite movie of
all time is ghostbusters the original
that's that's it I love that movie to
death it's probably the movie I've seen
more than any other that's my favorite
movie what is your favorite show and
favorite episode of that show well if
you couldn't guess favorite show is
Doctor Who favorite episode I I don't
know there was a reason that I rank you
know when I do top tens I don't do a top
10 for everything I break it down by
individual doctors cuz I'm able to do
that to try and like figure out a single
episode I did not honestly I can't I
just can't
which doctor arrow was more flawed Matt
Smith or Peter Capaldi if you hadn't
guessed there are a fair number of
Doctor Who questions I've tried to space
them out so I'm not just cramming for a
long stretch of Doctor Who so for this
one I'm not sure which is more flawed in
terms of the number of actual issues I'd
say the the manner in which they're
flawed is a little bit different and I
think I prefer the way in which Capaldi
Zahra was flawed because I think with
Smith he started out strong and then the
flaws the cracks got bigger as he went
to as his era went along
whereas Capaldi most of the weakest
stuff at least for me and what I liked
was all front-loaded like every series
with Capelli
got better and for me if you're gonna
have you know a little bit of unevenness
it's not always great I would rather
start on the lower end and get better
than start great and then get weird and
wobbly from there so yeah I suppose to
my preferences Smith's is more flawed
what is your favorite thing to talk
about on YouTube I honestly don't know
you think I would just say Doctor Who
except you know I just I feel like
picking a favorite be like this is what
I wish I could talk about all the time
and there is no one thing like that I
think my favorite thing about YouTube
right now is how quickly I've gotten
able to turn these things around which
enables me to talk about basically
whenever an idea pops into my head to
talk about it that I can just sit down
and do that I love being able to just
roll with a
Oshin almost as soon as it hits me
that's a lot of fun regardless of what
the specific topic is do you have a
favorite episode of Gotham so far I do
my favorite episode of Gotham is from
season 2 it is this ball of mud and
meanness which is an episode that is so
good that it's actually the episode that
I tend to recommend to people who I know
who like watched a couple of episodes of
the first season and then we're like oh
this isn't any good I tell them check
out this ball of mine and meanness if
you see that you still don't want to see
more fine but it's it's the one that I
recommend that people who are skeptical
about the show check out this episode it
actually works pretty well as a
standalone if you know anything about
Batman at all you can get exactly what's
going on and it's phenomenal I noticed
you were wearing a D&D shirt during the
it roundtable do you play yeah I I do
have a gaming group it's kind of on
hiatus right now because Paul you know
one about one of the more frequent
collaborators on here who I mentioned
had a kid he hosted and ran most of the
games so I don't DM I'm I no way would I
be any good at that but and we haven't
always played the same thing we've
generally kept jumping campaigns and he
and Paul didn't always D I'm like Ryan
deemed a Star Wars campaign where I
played a I played a droid slicer and
that that was a lot of fun we've had a
zombie one we've done Call of Cthulhu we
did transformers on a whim that was oh
that was interesting and we did do a
more traditional D&D one I was a
half-orc barbarian and and at one point
I ended up having a elves leg like not
like as a thing like one of my legs
became an elf leg that was that was also
interesting I had briefly considered
actually starting to record those gaming
sessions and edit them into is something
that I could do as a podcast ultimately
that got scrapped because as I said the
our ability to meet up and do the gaming
night is pretty inconsistent at this
point but but yeah I do game and it's a
lot of fun have you listened to the war
master only the good box set from Big
Finish so
Doctor Who fans I have started doing Big
Finish reviews I there was a sale on big
finished up and I bought a whole bunch
of it I'm not gonna say what I bought
the reason being I don't want to find
out ahead of time what people's opinions
of these things are I don't want I don't
want to give a list of what I'm planning
doing people go oh this was great or oh
you gotta listen to that one but I want
to come in cold and fresh as much as
possible because I want to give things a
fair chance even if other people don't
think they're great how or more
importantly I don't really want stuff
over height for me because I've had that
happen to me with a lot of classic stuff
before there's a number of classic
episodes that I need to go back and see
you again because they had been hyped up
for me so much before I saw them that
when I saw them I was like that's fine
and I am say I am subject to overhype so
I'm not gonna say what Big Finish is I
bought but I bought enough I'm set for
at least the next year in terms of
talking about those why did you delete
my comment and then actually there was a
it was a bit more after that that was
less pleasantly asked so people have
noted that I do respond to comments not
all of them but when I feel like there's
something that I can add to a
conversation or somebody makes a really
good point I'm I will reply that also
means that I moderate the comments
section to a certain degree and there
are a number of reasons that I may
choose to remove comments but 99% of the
time it's because it contains a personal
attack either against me against another
commenter against you know a creator or
an actor about whatever it is whatever
pop culture thing it is I'm talking
about and I still I don't want personal
attacks on my channel now I if you're
wondering yeah
I'm pretty sure most of the stuff that I
delete is from people who disagree with
me but I try really hard to not have
that be the reason I delete stuff but
that is more often than not what I end
up deleting because let's be honest if
someone disagrees with me or what I said
made them angry they're kind of more
likely to be indulging in personal
attacks that's not as I said that's not
the only reason I am Hugh
I'm not above you know coming to the
comments section in a bad mood and just
going I'm not dealing with that I'm not
dealing with this and clearing some
stuff out I try really hard to not do
that and I've even had some occasions
where I've deleted coming literally by
accident I've had some that got flagged
for review and I looked at him and I
meant to hit approved and I hit delete
and said that has happened and I
freaking hate that because I mean that's
just that's my base rule in terms of my
comment section you know avoid
pejorative terms don't tell people to go
kill themselves and don't wish cancer on
my mother cuz yeah that happened have
you thought about doing a Red Dwarf
video how long have you been a fan of
the small Rouge ones so a few people
picked up the fact that I've dropped the
occasional red dwarf reference in two
videos here and there and yes I have
been a fan of Red Dwarf I think since
about 8th grade so for a very long time
I haven't really considered doing a
video partly because I actually haven't
seen the most recent episodes but also
beyond that I'm not sure that I have
anything to add like I'm not sure what
there is for me to say other than I
really like this show why did you stop
using the green screen did you think it
made you look too much like a ghost
so newer subscribers which is most of
you who may not be aware of the fact
that I used to use a green screen and I
don't anymore and the reason I backed
off from it was actually much more
logistical than the fact that I couldn't
really get the effect to work properly
that I think was I probably chalk that
up to the editing software I've been
using I recently just bought a new
editing software so I'm hoping that some
things that have been issues will stop
being issues and potentially that might
mean the green screen too doesn't mean
I'm gonna bring it back cuz it's just a
pain in the butt and it adds time for me
to incorporate that whereas this I I
literally I just sit down I check I
checked my lighting and I go and that's
a big part of why I've been able to
crank out video content at the pace that
I have so cutting out the green screen
wasn't intended to like result in me
doing more videos but it kind of has
because it saves me time you've
mentioned your daughter are you a single
father and actually
this is a another one that had some
other stuff coming in after that which I
was very flattered by um so yes I am a
father I am no longer with my daughter's
mother we are still amazing friends we
were friends even before we got married
so you know I have a absolutely
wonderful relationship with her mother
but we are not together however I am
also not single I am with someone I have
a partner who I have been with for about
a year and a half now so I am a father
not with the mother of my child but also
not single
have you ever watch the TV show The Big
Bang Theory I'll try and keep this short
because I could easily fill up a whole
video on this but I the Big Bang Theory
just so much from the core of my being I
hate that show now to be fair I have not
watched an episode front to back end to
end because I can't watch more than five
minutes before I want to pull my hair
out and scream at the screen so to make
it as short as I can you don't get
points from me by making your main
characters Deeks or nerds but you are
still making the exact same look how
weird and awkward people who are good at
science or people who like sci-fi are
that have been made in pop culture since
friggin Revenge of the Nerds you don't
get points just because you made them
the main characters if you're still
doing the same old stale tired look at
the awkward nerve jokes you also don't
get points just because you get
references to comic books and Doctor Who
whatever right I'm not giving you points
for that if you're still making junk
that isn't funny I got to move off this
because I got a lot of bile towards that
show have you ever done cosplay if not
do you have any characters you would
like to do I have done cosplay I started
going to conventions only in the last
couple years local stuff to me
yeah Vermont Comic Con in Boston Comic
Con because that's not that far away in
terms of what characters I've done stick
a pin in that we're gonna come back to
it but for right now short answer yes I
have done cosplay how did you come to
love Doctor Who was there a specific
episode that
when you over or was it a process oh and
what is it that you liked most about the
show so kind of three questions crammed
together but let's get to it
Doctor Who is something I was aware of
as a thing I can probably sense out late
grade school because my friends who had
PBS who watched it I never got into it
at that age what got me hooked was my my
my daughter's mother and I we were in
London for our honeymoon and we were
there for a week which is a perfect
amount of time to be in a place like
London because it's enough time to do
all the touristy things you need to do
like the London Eye and and see the
crown jewels and whatnot but it's also
enough time to just chill and relax and
not have to be on a crazy schedule to be
sure you cram everything in so we had a
period of downtime and I found myself
flipping through the TV channels and I
stopped on an ood and I stopped on a new
because I looked and I went that looks
like a mind flayer from D&D and I'm I
just got sucked in initially by that and
then it was the episode the Satan pit
was what it was and I wasn't in at the
very beginning came in maybe between a
third and half way in but I'm just
watching and there was one moment that
made me go I need to start watching this
and it was when Tennant was being
lowered down into the pit and he hit the
end of the rope the the end of the cable
he looks down and all he sees is
blackness he says it could be miles yet
to go
or it could be 30 feet I could survive
30 feet I'm like I love this I love
everything about this so that was what
made me make the decision I need to
catch up on this so as soon as I got
back home I started catching up on from
Eccleston forward you know through
Netflix and then starting with series
four I was watching it as it aired so
that was how I got introduced to the
Doctor Who what I loved most about it is
it it feeds my inner seven year old
because at its heart it is about a man
with a magic box who can it can take him
anywhere like that that is pure
imagination to me I love that today
favorite video game of all time final
fantasy 6 I knew it as Final Fantasy 3
at the time that I was playing it you
know back on the old Super Nintendo but
Final Fantasy 6 and I loved it so much
that even though I don't normally do
video game content I might do a long
rambling video just going on and on
about how much I loved that game cuz I
loved that game do you ever watch your
old videos once in a while and take note
of what you remember feeling back then
and think of how you feel now um not as
much as I used to and that's likely
Jilly just because I create so much new
content now that if I was regularly
going back and Andry looking at my old
stuff I wouldn't have time to make new
stuff anymore at this point if I do it
it's normally if I am revisiting a topic
that I discussed before to some occasion
to see what I said about it before and
that's not to be like I must be
consistent and say the same thing I said
last time but if my pain has changed
from the last time I talked about
something I want to be able to
acknowledge that I want to say okay you
know I did a previous video and said
this my feelings have changed now it's
this which I you know there's a weird
sort of thing where people were like
really put on a pedestal the notion of
always holding the same idea never
wavering and I don't know why we
celebrate pigheadedness that way but it
like in my case if my opinion has
changed I want to be able to acknowledge
that and sometimes I go back and find
out oh look at that my opinion hasn't
changed cool based on the fact that so
far Chris Chibnall has only written five
unanimously Matt or even bad within the
Doctor Who fandom episodes are you
worried about what he's bringing to the
table as showrunner so Chris Chibnall is
taking over as the showrunner for Doctor
Who and this is one that I I'm basically
just gonna plug a future video I am
planning to do a retrospective all the
stuff he's written related to Doctor Who
and I say related because he only had
five episodes of the show proper but he
also did a whole bunch of Torchwood so
I'm gonna be kind of doing an overview
of all the stuff that he's written and
sort of seeing what my assessment is at
that point because I need to re-watch
some of it so that's coming do you want
to see another Superman movie weirdly
yes
more to the point I want to see another
one when Henry Cavill because I actually
thought he did really well playing the
more Boy Scout hopeful version of
Superman that we got to see him be in
Justice League I thought he was actually
much better at that than the whole
broody self-doubting thing they were
having him do up to that point so I
really hope he gets a chance to play
that version of Superman in at least one
more film and I don't think it's as hard
to do a good Superman movie as you
thought I mean like I said go see
Superman versus the Elite Four like just
an idea of ways to approach this
character to really show why having him
be hopeful and inspirational is
important still and can still work as a
narrative this one was an interesting
one if you could travel back in time and
take credit for any film book TV show
etc which one would it be alright if
we're talking about a single piece of
work it would be the last unicorn by
Peter s vehicle because if you've never
at that book or if you've only seen the
movie which I love the movie but that
book is it's a speaking of someone who
actually does have aspirations as a
fiction writer that book is so
beautifully written it made me angry and
I would actually have to pause every few
chapters because I was just left
thinking nobody is supposed to be able
to be this good and write this
beautifully and sustain it for a whole
book that's just not fair so if it was a
single piece I'd want credit for that if
it was somebody's career with this stuff
I think it would be a toss-up between
Douglas Adams or Neil Gaiman what is
your favorite animated series of all
time this is one that I have talked
about before it was a while ago though
but it's the max the MTV oddities
animated series of the max from the 90s
I like it might honestly be my favorite
piece of completed television not my
favorite show of all time
that's Doctor Who but in terms of
something that began and ended and is
closed off and it's done so you know
compare it to any show that is finished
its run
I think the max is my favorite completed
piece of television what do you think of
the current state of the DCE you should
they reboot or keep going in the
direction they're going in if you'd
asked me this before Justice League I
would have said reboot at this point I
kind of hope they don't because Justice
League very much looks like they are
trying to correct in universe and stand
while Justice League while it was for me
a pleasant surprise of a movie is still
not great it does feel like it is moving
towards the direction at least work I
would like to see things go more and if
they're already correcting in universe
rebooting on top of that feels like
overkill like you've already started the
correction just correct in universe
because you already started the most
Awkward step up you know your first
movie that is redirecting the feel and
the vibe of everything is now behind you
so just do things the new way you want
to do them at this point I don't think a
reboot is necessary anymore the way that
I felt that it might have been necessary
before Justice League came out did you
ever hear that Capaldi was supposed to
regenerate at the end of series 10
Moffat then changes mine and wrote a
Christmas regeneration I hadn't heard
that if it's true that's annoying
because actually I would really like to
take the regenerations off of Christmas
specials what I would like to see happen
is the last episode of whatever their
proper series that's where we get the
regeneration and then the Christmas
special is the first adventure of the
new doctor that's what I would like to
see them start doing so if they almost
did that and then chickened out honestly
that irritates me what is the most
disappointing series finale you've ever
seen Dexter no question hands-down
absolute worst the series finale for
Dexter is so bad that I actually have a
really hard time going back and even
watching the seasons that I love like
season two or four but I can't watch
them anymore because there's a thing in
the back of my head going none of this
matters because it still ends in that
horrible friggin ending it's really
atrocious I have a video on it you can
dig through and and find out a ways
back but oh god that's a monstrosity all
right I'm gonna do three in a row here
that are all related to one of my
podcasts so for context one of the
features of the council of geeks podcast
feed is 90's comics retrial where I go
through and review the comic books that
I bought during the 1990s do you hate
yourself if not why is it that you
choose to subject yourself to such awful
90s x-men comics for other people's
audio entertainment will we ever get
another 90s comics free trial episode
covering more issues of Sam Keith's max
third question any ramifications for
your blasphemous views of 90s x-men
animated series okay I'll try and hammer
through this one even though these
questions are geared towards the x-men
I've actually got different collections
so I basically my 90s comics break down
into four categories there is spider-man
x-men image and then miscellaneous so
yeah the x-men stuff has been pretty bad
I don't hate myself the thing was I
started listening to comic book based
podcast and decided I kind of want to do
one but I don't have the expertise that
a lot of the shows I was listening to
have like they would really zero in on a
specific character and they do like an
index show of all their appearances or
you know things like that I'm like I
don't have that level of expertise and
nor do I have a collection that would
sustain that so thinking about what I
already had to handle mine I've just got
a long box full of old 90s comics and
nobody likes 90s comics and huh there's
a premise in that and so that's how the
show got started I do have one other
issue of the max that will show up on
90s comics retrial eventually I'm not
sure when yet I because at this point my
collection for the max is the trades the
actual issues I only had three and I've
reviewed two of them already and finally
the reference to my blasphemous take on
the 90s x-men cartoon there have not
been ramifications for that but that's
because way fewer people listened to my
podcast then watch this channel so there
may be random malefic Asians now when I
point out that I don't think the 90s
x-men cartoon holds up really well
at all I think it's
it kind of stinks and now that I've said
that here with a lot more people seeing
and hearing it yeah there may be
ramifications which might have been the
questioners intent all along hmm
well-played what was the first movie you
ever bought yourself or were given as a
gift I'm not entirely sure for both
giving us a gift I had no idea I grew up
on movies because growing up I didn't
really have TV maybe my mom my mother
hated TV she hated the news and she
hated commercials so we didn't even get
things in on the rabbit ears um I did
still watch stuff my grandmother who was
a saint and had cables she would record
my favorite cartoons that actually sit
through them and stop recording so there
so I have these VHS a--'s with the
commercials cut out for things like
he-man and Thundercats and Ghostbusters
and a bunch of Disney stuff and and
things like that but you know but I've
been getting movies as gifts for longer
than I can even remember first one that
I bought for myself the first one that I
remember buying for myself was x-men on
VHS because I think prior to that I was
pretty much just getting stuff gifted to
me that that I liked that's the first
one I can really remember going out of
my way to buy though so I think that
might have been it all right what I've
got now is a list of lightening opinions
because there were a number of people
who basically we're asking my opinion on
this movie or TV show or whatever so I'm
just gonna burn through these real quick
pulp fiction I like it I feel it's
overrated this is one of those cases
where I think it was severely overhyped
by the time that I saw it
Shawshank Redemption really good movie I
think some people really put it at a
higher level than I do
to a degree that I'm like I'm not sure
it's greatest movie of all time but it's
a really good movie The Matrix love it
amazing spider-man 2 along with Batman V
Superman the premiere example of what
happens when you put too much concern on
franchise building than actually telling
a coherent story where the Miller's
haven't seen it lego ninjago it was good
it was fun it wasn't great it was it's
the lesser of the lego movies released
so far but still better than a lot of
other animated stuff I've seen in the
last couple years Horrible Bosses
haven't seen it Reservoir Dogs I
I get better than Pulp Fiction Harry
Brown haven't seen it Kill Bill 1 & 2
seen them both like them both I do
consider them separate movies and I
consider Kill Bill Vol 2 to be my own
personal favorite movie that Tarantino
has made and now a couple of quick
comparatives Breaking Bad or better call
Saul well I haven't seen better call
Saul yet so Breaking Bad wins by default
Game of Thrones are stranger things at
this point diamonds Game of Thrones but
it's kind of unfair because stranger
things only having two seasons and the
fact that I had a lot of disappointment
with the second season we need to see if
a third season brings it back to where I
really loved it like it did in the first
season so it's kind of unfair to compare
them at this point after they've been a
couple more seasons of stranger things I
could say more definitively but if you
gotta press me against the wall it's
gonna be Game of Thrones but I think
it's too early to call that Doctor Who
or Sherlock well Doctor Who obviously
but it would have been closer if the
last series of Sherlock hadn't gone off
a friggin cliff so ok I've got one more
I'm gonna take a nipper courage on this
one so this last one this is a question
that I've actually gotten a few times
over the last year or so and I debated
whether or not to answer it I've decided
that I'm going to and I'm gonna show you
the question I'm gonna answer the
question and then I'm going to explain
after that so if the question does not
make immediate sense it will in a minute
are you very wild yes I am this is not
my first youtube channel it's not even
the only one that I currently run the
other one that I run is very wild and
that is a channel primarily dedicated to
discussing issues related to and
answering questions about cross-dressing
and gender fluidity because my own
personal sense of gender is something
that doesn't stay put so you know I
choose to present as you see me I'm when
I do this channel and this and I am
perfectly comfortable doing this but if
you were to see me sort of more
left to my own devices day-to-day like
just around my own home that might be a
little more along the lines of this so
yeah I haven't presented this way on
this channel for a number of reasons
largely just because I don't think the
things that I talked about on the very
wild channel are especially relevant to
my feelings on geeky subjects so it
never made sense like to cross-pollinate
between the two and this was also why I
stuck a pin in the question of whether
or not I have done cosplay because the
cosplay that I have done is Wonder Woman
and poison ivy which is why I have those
Lego figures my partner bought those for
me those two years that I went to
Vermont comic-con as Wonder Woman in
that poison ivy she bought me the Lego
figures so my talking about this and
kind of acknowledging it here on this
channel is like I said it's something I
debated I'm not gonna start talking
about that side of my life here again
just because I don't think it's
especially relevant and while this is a
channel driven by me and my opinions
it's meant to be about pop culture and
while you know this this and and you
know the very wild stuff is an aspect of
my life that feeds into where some of my
opinions come from I still I still feel
like it would be distracting but you may
now also be realizing this is why
sometimes you see me with nail polish
there were a couple of earlier videos
that I made some lame excuses as to why
I had nail polish on which I'm a little
embarrassed that I did now which I
suppose is the other thing because like
I said I've been getting this question
off and on for know about a year or so
and basically from people who knew my
very wild channel first and
and then found this one and that's not
as jarring I don't think because you see
me on there and you know you hear me
talk about the fact that I don't have a
consistent presentation of my gender and
I have you know times I present more
masculine times I present more feminine
and if you are aware of me from that and
then you come here it makes sense like
oh this is a more masculine presentation
fine I started to worry though about
especially with the channel growing the
way it has about people who know me from
this first finding the very wild channel
and having I guess a more visceral
negative reaction to that revelation and
that's another thing I expect a certain
degree of fall out from acknowledging
and talking about this and but I would
rather have that happen now and know
that whatever I build going forward from
here isn't threatened by you know people
exposing that's the wrong term really
but sort of trying to bring this up in
an effort to damage me like I I want to
address it on my terms because if this
gets brought up as some sort of means of
attack or oh god shows like why you are
you hiding this because I'm not trying
to I did there isn't a really
particularly thick wall between you know
what I do here and the the very wild
stuff it's not that hard to figure out
if you've ever find both things but I if
if I had to react to someone else
bringing it up first that brings an
inherent sense of that I was hiding it
or that I'm somehow ashamed and I'm not
because that's not me I I am not ashamed
at all
I just don't present this way on this
channel because again I don't think it's
I don't think this side of my life has
been particularly relevant to what I
talked about here and also at this point
it's partly its branding
like I know the cap the glasses that I
wear it's a consistent look and that
helps things to a certain extent if you
have more questions about about this
side of my life you can check out the
very wild channel it doesn't get updated
as regularly as it used to but it does
still get updates and there's plenty of
backlog stuff on there and it and it
very well is also a performance thing I
mentioned getting that rubber duck at a
burlesque show I perform dragon
burlesque as as Varys oh yeah it's a
it's pretty big significant important
part of my life just not one that I had
addressed here prior to this and even as
I'm talking about this there's part of
me that wonders like I am I gonna get to
the edge and cut this out and completely
lose my nerve I don't know we'll see I
hope not and I've had more than a few
occasions where stuff that I've talked
about that I thought was gonna result in
a complete disaster in you know the
comments or what have you
I've had that not happen sometimes I've
had other times that it's gone
completely south so we'll see which way
it goes I'd like to be pleasantly
surprised but that's also part of the
reason why I'm talking about this at the
very end of this video because I figure
the only people who stick this far into
a Q&A video are people who are genuinely
curious and interested about me and I'd
like to think that those people would be
more receptive to to this and to me so
yeah I think well we'll go back to what
you're more used to seeing ah
so switch that out and there we go see
how easy that was
so that'll wrap this up folks 10,000
subscribers that closes the Q&A I just
want to thank everybody this has been
really phenomenal and I hope that the
growth
I have started to see maintains it's
actually keeping picking up even more
which is crazy to me um I don't know
what the ceiling on this is but I don't
think another 10,000 subscribers is
complete insanity and I say that as
someone who didn't think I would ever
get to 10,000 I figured I would get to a
thousand it took me a long time to get
there but I figured I would if I kept
things up I never thought I'd get to
10,000 so thank you you guys are amazing
and phenomenal and whatever your
thoughts are on any of the things I have
brought up drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it do all
things like subscribe whatever links to
all my other stuff is below Twitter
Email the podcast and whatnot so until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]